from warren buffett's perspective i  think it's hard when you've made your  fortunes one way to be able to see it  another way right like he made his  fortunes from the traditional market he  understands that that's proven for him  unfortunately it's hard to teach an old  dog new tricks and so i i totally  understand his perspective right but the  issue is peter till is this libertarian  right so it's not about technology for  him it's about understanding the  fundamental value of having money which  isn't centralized and money which can't  be changed it's fixed the laws are fixed  everything is set in stone so as a  libertarian he understands that